south dakota governor christie gnome
governor my analysis is correct
that in spite of saying that only the
rich are going to pay in these evil
corporations pay
i argue this will be paid for by the
average american person it doesn't
matter how much you make you're
that's right you're exactly right sean
every single family will pay the price
for what joe biden's agenda is he will
drive up the cost of the food
and their grocery bill he will drive up
the cost of their utilities
their gas prices the cost of their cars
the clothes they dress their children in
everything that they do each and every
day will be more expensive
their budgets will be tighter because
they'll be earning less and it'll be
directly because of these policies
and these tax increases that joe biden
is embracing and pushing through
congress
okay let's talk more about what does it
mean for people in your state of south
dakota
tell us how this will impact them good
well i served in congress when we did
the tax cuts with president trump i was
on the ways and means committee and on
the conference committee that negotiated
the final package
in south dakota we put 2 400 back in the
pockets
of each and every family here and we saw
our economy grow
in fact nationwide after we did that
bill and cut taxes we saw federal
revenues
increase because we had economic growth
in the country
exactly what president trump said was
going to happen
happened and we were better for it
people were
out there spending more money because
they had more money in their pockets
they were able to do more take a
vacation maybe buy a new car and it was
directly because president trump
recognized
that people made better decisions with
their dollars than the government did
and they should have the right to spend
them how they saw fit now with what
the white house is proposing i was on a
call with the white house today with all
the governors talking about the
specifics of this package
and i was shocked by how much doesn't go
into infrastructure
it goes into research and development it
goes into housing
and pipes and different initiatives
green energy
and it really is not an honest
conversation we're having
about what this proposal is so i'm
frustrated
i recognize that this is not going to be
good for the country it's not going to
be good for the people that live here in
south dakota
and we're going to be back here a couple
of years from now
wishing that we weren't in a situation
where people had less money
all their costs were increased and the
country was declining
and low tax states like yours and the
last you know
two trillion dollar covert emergency
relief the blue state bailout bill
paid for in large part by citizens in
states like yours that are far more
fiscally responsible
quick word you have very strong words
about these vaccine passports
we'll have more on it later in the
program your thoughts
your initial thoughts on it i think it's
un-american
this is something that we're going to
fight and not allow to happen and we
should
across the country fight this kind of an
agenda to have this kind of
policy going forward and pushed by the
federal government's unacceptable
all right governor noam good to see you
and uh good job you have been doing
republican governor has been doing great
it's new york new jersey
pennsylvania michigan california that's
where the big problems are